[Musik]
die neuen wege tun wenn ich mich da die
ganze familie partner muttertag wetter
ist aber mal wieder so richtig und point
dann bin ich noch ein bisschen ist das
ein am montag ist und ich für meine
stadt ist ein richtiges geschenk
das heißt ich muss nicht nur im
rheinland eine meinung haben die
beziehung zur mutter
damit knüpfe aufgebaut bei diesen
menschen glaube ich einfach noch auf
darstellen und ihrer mutter sohn
beziehung im moment an griechenland auf
der y-achse ist der grad der beziehung
also wie verbundene miteinander ist das
jetzt einfach die dauer in jahren
startet hier im alter von neun jahren
als beziehung zur mutter relativ hoch
und der kreislauf ist ein bisschen das
so bleibt dann geht sie ganz runter und
dann geht's zum ende hin wieder hoch
hier in diesem abschnitt ist nämlich
einfach in der kindheit mentalist in
kindergarten und hier kommt man in die
grundschule und wird einfach
eigenständiger man kommt in die pubertät
und da ist die mutter einfach voll am
nerven hier unten wenn man allerdings
wieder älterwerden das merke ich jetzt
gerade mit 21 ist man schon wieder hier
auf dem weg und irgendwann will man
natürlich wieder hier oben sein und mit
der mutter komplett verbunden sein und
das hier ist dann glaube ich immer so
wenn man einfach ausgewachsen ist
vernünftig drauf weil es irgendwie 30
bis 40 jahre alt aber wie gesagt befinde
ich mich wahrscheinlich gerade irgendwo
hier auf dem weg wieder richtig krachen
beziehung zu meiner mutter weil ich
komme gerade aus der pubertären die
mutter
möchte man sollte natürlich immer die
beziehung aufrecht halten weil es ist
einfach die person im leben ohne die man
nicht leben würde wie ihn werde ich
jetzt einfach mal meine mutter schon mal
anrufen bevor ich nach hause fahren
werde bei mama alles gute zum muttertag
die wir komplette blog wird natürlich
nicht irgendwie nur meiner mutter
gewidmet sein und total langweilig sein
und nur so familientag mäßig aber heute
ist halt und muttertag und ich bleibe
oder als meiner familie gelingt wäre
froh darüber zu sprechen bekommt noch
übertrumpfen kommentare von den eltern
gestellt wie er fast jeden tag irgendwo
im internen jahr weil ich einfach der
ansicht wenn wirklich mir lieber 14 euro
und gekochtes essen von dem koch aus
köln liefern latte und dann in der zeit
wo ich eigentlich auch selber kochen
können drei euro gestarteten derzeit
wieder aufnehmen oder so was wie jetzt
gerade euch die bilder animationen da
diese präsentation runter in die 2
bei mir ist mittlerweile wurde das
wichtigste gut in meinem leben ist und
war noch mehr geld also dann bin ich
eher der meinung ok werden mit dem geld
für das bettenhaus und hab dann halten
mit mehr zeit ruhig was anders machen
kann stellen kann lernen kann oder sogar
gebracht aber eine kirche setzt noch
stühle mussten einkauf noch unklar um
was man muss außerdem sagen scheint
mittlerweile wenn man es im internet
bestellten einfach fast so gering sind
wie wenn man selber kochen würde also
mit 234 euro mehr oder suchen daher
würde ich sagen
[Applaus]
ich habe die letzten drei stunden im
blog von selbst angeschnittene relativ
lang geworden weil wir so viel gefilmt
aber ich werde jetzt auch meine sachen
packen und nicht so langsam auch im weg
nach hause zu meiner familie nach
bielefeld machen das wirklich
muttertagsgeschenk werden um eine kleine
tage schönen tag und abend verliehen
schenkt nur die afrikaner wo ich drauf
bleiben werde dass ich ihr den
plakativen problem hätten werde weil sie
mir in der zweiten hat dass ich damit
ein problem hat bei jeder frage und
jedem problem von mir waschen et cetera
immer direkt für jederzeit weiter
geholfen hat dies hier ein gutschein
dass du mich zu jeder zeit wirklich
iphone fragen oder keine ahnung wovon
für fragen kann ich liebe die kugel
geben wenn ich zu hause bin mit ruhigen
menschen aber hey komm vom herzen
ihre energie date movie youtube ich
befinde mich jetzt im auto hinter mir
geht schön die sonne unter oder gar
nicht so genau
es ist tatsächlich gerade schon 8 uhr
ich wollte eigentlich um die moral
meiner eltern gehen ich hab dir
verbringen werde ich bin erst um halb
zehn in bielefeld gewinnen aber so
freundlich
wahrscheinlich sollte wenn ich habe
bereits vor eintreffen werde
[Musik]
alles gute zum muttertag
wir haben allesamt aufgegeben meine
eltern sind zu fuß nach hause gelaufen
ich mit dem auto weil ich halt direkt
vom restaurant gefahren werden wir auf
jeden fall wäre schön mal meine familie
jetzt nach drei vier wochen nur in köln
am wieder zu sehen
meine mutter hat sich auch tatsächlich
wäre aber das geschenk gefreut
ich bin wieder zu hause in meinem zimmer
das ist so traurig immer wenn ich zu
hause bin wenige fitnessgeräte man immer
von meinen eltern und für mich ich bin
auf jeden fall wieder zu hause
angekommen auf mich warten wir schon
einige pakete die ich noch eben auch
machen danke ein leben das die mir lego
city an der körper zugesteckt haben ich
werde dazu keine videos machen legen
arbeit wird spielen also danke schön
alles technisch aber bisschen abschalten
der aufmerksame luca auch instagram und
cnet folge reist dass ich dies auch
vorteile besitze ich fahr damit er jetzt
halt nicht so und rentierte bei mir in
meinem aufnahmen abriss oder so das
macht aber ich hab halt weil die damals
cool fand in ein arsch bequem die schuhe
und dachten halt die echten hit worden
sich da habe allerdings fand ich die
paris bleibt auch mal folglich wir genau
in den farben rot schwarz und sollten
auch vorstellen einfach irgendwie noch
mal so eine erste stinknormale natur
auszugeben das muss man halt allerdings
vertragen dass die auch vorstellen
einfach auch in der lage sind also ich
trage ich wäre hätten unter dem zustand
wie egal dann können die 700 euro
verkaufen kein boxer gute gelten schuhe
sind klein und allgemein
deswegen habe ich mir sechs besteht also
verwies red black an der stelle noch mal
an da wird er mir
courtial als das sind jetzt auch felix
die wm eigentlich fast genauso aus die
echten nur wirkliche kenner wieder den
unterschied und ich meine kriegsjahre
auf 180 euro einfach gekürzt wird und
kommen aus amerika deswegen ja leute
also ich gehe da ganz offen zu ich weiß
dass kate damit auch fähig hatte bisher
auch immer noch eine perry playback auf
youtube thema werde jetzt natürlich
ankommen und werden sagen verdient übels
viele morgen könnte doch einfach alles
kaufen gibt ja aber darum geht nicht
darum das ist eine menge geld ist für
einfach ein paar schuhe
hammergeil china geruch schau mal was
drin ist also auf jeden fall erstmal die
schuhe die triplex hier
ich weiß nicht an alle die wie kenner
beziehungsweise mode leute die sich
auskennen ich glaube man sieht es nur
noch an dass die lasche ein bisschen an
anderen stellen oder wenn ich mich so
auf der straße sehen würde dann würde
ich sagen ist ein echter also ich weiß
nicht wie oder warum er sich ganz offen
zu dass ich fähig haben und dafür finden
dadurch eine echte werden oder so
gehalten dass ich okay was habe ich
keinen bock darauf 800 euro für schuhe
auszugeben und weisen jetzt noch einfach
dass ich keinen bock habe mit über ibm
mit leuten treffen kontakte westen nur
um die echten zu bekommen und die sind
dann auch schon gelaufen worden dass ich
beklage nicht mehr die schnüre ich für
sich genommen so sehen die aus also ich
habe jetzt nicht die mühe gemacht auch
im kino zu machen und socken anzuziehen
und keine ahnung was ja auch noch mal
die rechnung die dabei war bei 100 euro
an
geburtstag auf welches ich kenne mich
damit überhaupt nicht aus die daten sind
auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt schon oft
genug gesagt aber das hält mich nicht
dass wir die gebraucht wird gegner schon
aufgewacht warum ich ich muss sich alles
mal 1000 mal sagen etwas anderes was
auch angekommen ist ist die hallo mein
name luca bettwäsche aus wie lukas nach
fünfeinhalb monaten
habe ich dann auch mal ein exemplar
bekommen und jetzt nochmal an euch hier
die wirklich den blog jetzt schon fast
zu ende geschaut haben eine info nbbl
wäsche wird eine zweite auflage auch am
ersten weckten luca shop erscheinen das
ist genau die gleiche wir haben aber
einfach nur noch mal fahrt bestände
wieder produziert also wird jetzt auf
jeden fall schon mal dass dieser
longsleeve mit dem 3d lut hupend und dem
etwas ausgefransten kragen und dem zeit
print dass dort auf jeden fall am ersten
weg den lukas sein wird und zudem auch
noch restbestände von der bettwäsche
dort verein werden also wie gesagt er
weckte 15 uhr das aber auch wenn es eine
freiheit wie gesagt das gerne mal leicht
da und ich würde wirklich brauchen
[Musik]